I have to tell you Michael Bloomberg is
doing something absolutely hilarious
because it shows how easily trigger able
Donald Trump is Michael Bloomberg is
trolling Donald Trump about his weight
and remember that this is something
Trump is very triggering about by all
serious accounts Donald Trump is
clinically obese now he officially
claims to be six foot three inches tall
and weigh 239 pounds if true that puts
him like a pound below clinically obese
but nobody believes that height Trump is
pictured in net in a number of pictures
he's standing next to people known to be
shorter than six three and Trump is very
clearly shorter than them so we know
this is a very sensitive topic for
Donald Trump the alpha male this is an
ad that Michael Bloomberg put together
where he specifically uses what are
known as fat pics of Donald Trump
playing golf now I'm not calling them
fat pics pejoratively these are specific
pictures of Donald Trump playing golf in
like an all-white very light khakis and
a white shirt where he is known to be
absolutely furious when these pictures
are used because okay he looks extremely
large in them and Trump doesn't like
looking this way check it out it even
includes a picture of Trump looking
visibly exhausted and sort of climbing
to reach what looks like an errant golf
ball that he shot off the course take a
look people have said when you were
mayor the city gave Trump a contract to
operate a golf course yes
that's true but he was the only bidder
and running a golf course is the only
job that I would hire them for I'm Mike
Bloomberg Anaya proved this message it
is now being reported by Charlie Gasperi
no no left wing bomb thrower he's a
reporter for box Fox Business Network
that the Bloomberg ads with the
so-called fat pics have made Trump
furious and that he's been melting down
privately and also tweeting endlessly
about Michael Bloomberg who he has
dubbed mini Mike Trump tweeting in close
succession quote mini Mike is part of
the fake news they are all working
together in fact Bloomberg isn't
covering himself to boring to do or
other Dems only Trump that sounds fair
it's all the fake news media and that's
why nobody believes in them anymore can
10 Ewing to focus on mini mic saying
quote many of the ads you were watching
were paid for by mini Mike Bloomberg he
is going nowhere just wasting his money
but he is getting the DNC to rig the
election against crazy Bernie something
they wouldn't do for Cory Booker and
others they are going to do it again to
Bernie 2016 and then once again and this
one is actually hilarious Trump tweeting
so triggered mini mic is now negotiating
both to get on the Democrat primary
debate stage and to have the right to
stand on boxes or a lift during the
debates this is sometimes but not really
fair that is absolutely hilarious the
stuff Trump comes up with when he gets
triggered is so funny he also did
something Trump did that he rarely does
if ever which is he tweeted about
exercising now remember Donald Trump is
the guy who believes that when the human
body exercises it depletes some total
amount of energy that you have at your
disposal for life and so he's not a guy
who brags about exercising and yet after
the fat pick ad came out Donald Trump
tweeting a picture of himself golfing
with a caption getting a little exercise
this morning so regardless of
Bloomberg's chances and the chances
aren't great although I do believe it's
possible Mike Bloomberg could end up
third in delegates one if he continues
the strategy that we've outlined a
couple of weeks ago this is just
fantastic I would love to see Bloomberg
also do some ads that are compilations
of Trump's slurred speech you know the
United States of America god bless the
USA the Israeli city of Rome and that
that type of thing whoever is doing
these knows exactly what the trigger
points are for Donald Trump and is
exploiting them I saw that the Bloomberg
campaign is hiring some data science
people here in Massachusetts probably
another Super Tuesday States as well
clearly Bloomberg is not being shy about
laying out the cash and we can expect a
lot of action from Bloomberg I just hope
there's more of these ads that are
triggering Trump visibly on Twitter last
thing to clarify I'm not making fun of
obesity
do I find it funny it's a serious
medical condition what I'm pointing out
is that the supposed alpha male Trump
who's the best at everything both it's a
terrible diet doesn't exercise and is so
easily trigger Abul when you hit certain
pressure points and michael bloomberg is
taking advantage of those we have once
again multiple examples of these strange
brain glitches that some are calling
colloquially mini-strokes happening to
donald trump from last night's State of
the Union speech I don't know what this
is I am NOT a medical professional I
have gotten emails from neurologists who
say David these seem possibly like mini
strokes sometimes dementia can cause
this sometimes it can be medication it
can be drug abuse some say it's
parkinsonian I don't know what it is but
something is not right I'm going to play
for you two examples from last night
it's very visual so if you're listening
to the podcast or on the radio find the
video on our YouTube channel what
happens is that Donald Trump will
simultaneously mess up a word sort of
like the record skips and sometimes
he'll say a nonsense word and at the
exact same time his shoulders spasm and
he seems to sort of turn to cover it he
looks confused for a moment and then he
goes back to reading the teleprompter in
this first clip Donald Trump is trying
to read the word sanctuary from his
teleprompter we noticed this one live on
the state of the union stream last night
and instead Donald Trump says sanctuary
and right when he says it his body
spasms the shoulder twitch happens and
Trump turns let's take a look at this
first clip California passed an
outrageous law declaring their whole
state to be a stink cheeri for criminal
illegal the state of California passed
an outrageous law declaring their whole
state to be a stinking or for criminal
illegal the state of California passed
an outrageous Lord declare
again it's like the record skips from
mrs. or miss states all or part of a
word his shoulders spasm and then he
goes
back to reading after a brief moment of
confusion here's another example from
last night this one Trump is talking
he's either talking about Qasem
Soleimani or Abu Bakr al-baghdadi and
Trump was trying to say he directed the
December and he glitches he says that he
says that he directed December and
simultaneously the shoulders flinch from
spasms and then Trump turns to sort of
try to cover it almost like he knows
that it's happening honey orchestrated
the deaths of countless men women and
children he directed the December
dassault and went on to assault the US
forces in Iraq we're not making fun of
medical conditions we're noticing that
this is happening there's not an
explanation that has been given there's
no serious medical evaluation that's
been done of Donald Trump that we can
trust the one we have says he's 6-3 and
weighs 239 pounds if you believe that
I've got a bridge to sell you and this
does not seem normal now a couple of
other reminders of recent examples this
this was one on the word criminals at a
recent rally where the same type of
glitch happened Democrats decided to
shield and shelter look look wait you
have criminals all right watching the
president here in Wildwood New Jersey I
just wanna get a quick comment before we
toss it over to Tucker Molly Hemingway
and then remember another recent
instance of this while Donald Trump was
speaking to the right-wing group Turning
Point
USA begin by wishing you they were we
want to know what's going on quite
simply it is happening too much for it
to be nothing the confusion on Trump's
face the spasm and the recognition that
something seems to have happened that
Trump seems to experience suggests to me
this is not nothing what it is I don't
know I hope at some point we learn and
we figure it out let me know what you
think last night was the first of many
20/20 Democratic primaries in Iowa it is
in fact a
system so much anticipation finally the
2020 Democratic primary gets going
finally we are going to have some
information and data and numbers about
it is not just polls it is now voting
who takes the first win and
unfortunately it has turned into a
worldwide embarrassment headlines around
the world embarrassing for the
Democratic Party as multiple systems
apparently fell apart results simply
stopped being published after one or two
percent of the vote was out almost every
aspect of this has been a cartoonish
trainwreck and as of this recording we
do not know who won yesterday we were
streaming live yesterday a beautiful
live stream we had six or six thousand
or so people watching the entire evening
it got to be 9:30 p.m. Eastern and we
had just a few results it got to be
10:00 p.m. Eastern 10:30 p.m. Eastern
and we got a little bit more 11 p.m.
nothing and eventually just past 11:30
p.m. Eastern Time on our stream we
realized from looking at what various
DNC officials were putting out on
Twitter that the results were unlikely
to come out last night and that was it
for us for the night and as of this
morning we still do not know who won
yesterday's Iowa caucus now it is normal
that it can take a little while once you
have the final vote to get the final
numbers for what are called state
delegate equivalents but we are talking
about we don't even have the final vote
which is a preliminary number used to
sort of get an estimate of what the
state devil state delegate equivalents
are ultimately going to be now the
explanations that were being provided
have shifted the first explanation was
that the results were delayed because
the DNC is running them through quality
control that was already probably the
wrong lie to tell if an indeed was a lie
because that was interpreted by summers
we don't like the results and thus we
are delaying and seeing what we can do
to maybe change the results or wait for
results that the DNC is happier with to
come in so that they can release them
all at once and the were a lot of
people's minds went was this is meant to
hurt Bernie in some way shape or form
but it actually doesn't appear to be the
case it appears that that was merely a
cover again this is what we believe as
of right now it appears that the quality
control talking point was a cover for
what was a total breakdown and failure
of a technological system an IT
internet-based
app software system that was used to
tally and report the results of the Iowa
caucus by the time you hear this by the
time you watch today's show you may know
the results you may have a clearer
explanation as to what exactly happened
last night the DNC is saying that the
results are going to be released
sometime today now in the wake of this
multiple candidates have claimed to
either have internal numbers showing
that they won or gave speeches making it
sound like they won in fact Amy
Klobuchar did something hilarious last
night at around 11:15 I think it was
11:00 11:15 p.m. Eastern Time we had no
results Amy Klobuchar was in like fourth
or fifth place based on like 2% of the
vote at that time she came out and gave
a speech that seemed like a victory
speech even though she hadn't she
certainly wasn't in the lead and it she
certainly hadn't we didn't have enough
information to know whether anyone had
won she kind of gave a victory speech
which you know it was genius because
nothing was going on everything was
stopped and a whole bunch of networks
ended up covering the Klobuchar speech
even though she was like in fourth or
fifth place with about 10 percent of the
vote at the time then you had people
judge he Pete Budaj edgewood's that was
the early leader yesterday he put out a
statement kind of like implying he won
he says Iowa you have shocked the nation
I guess the real shock was how
incompetent the process was but Pete
Budaj edge with his comment suggesting I
guess that it was shocking that he was
doing so well at least in the early
numbers then Bernie Sanders Bernie
Sanders says that Bernie has his own
internal polling saying he got 29
percent of the vote Buddah jej 24
percent warned 21 with Joe Biden in a
distant fourth at 12 percent and we'll
talk about the Biden thing in a second
this is all now
being compounded by the claim that the
unreleased Des Moines Register poll from
the weekend had these results which were
Bernie first by Danforth yesterday I
told you that over the weekend the Des
Moines Register decided not to release
their last poll before voting because of
a claim that had been made that someone
who was interviewed for the poll said
when they asked me the question about
who I support and they read me the list
of candidates they didn't read every
candidate and that of course is a really
big deal when you were doing polling so
the Des Moines Register on that basis
said they were canceling the release of
the poll that however the the claim now
is from 538 that it was in that
unreleased poll Bernie 22 wore in 1816
and Biden 13 and that is very similar to
what Bernie's internal polling is
showing if these results or some version
of them are accurate this is a potential
game-changer for Joe Biden Joe Biden in
a sense had the most to lose last night
because as the longtime presumptive
frontrunner even though he was polling a
close second in Iowa going in yesterday
if Biden ends up with half of the
support that polling showed this is
extraordinarily damaging to Joe Biden
and if that's the case I wouldn't be
surprised to see the DNC establishment
rapidly shift likely to Pete Budaj edge
you would think maybe they would go to
Klobuchar but clovis hard that even
worse than Joe Biden yesterday based
just on those early results that we had
we'll see what the final numbers show
and that could be a disaster for Joe
Biden but then if you zoom out a little
bit and this is really the tragedy this
is a fiasco
that plays directly into Donald Trump's
hands who immediately started making fun
of the whole process on Twitter it's a
great effect and why wouldn't he the
process became a complete and total
farce Trump tweeting about how a coin
toss is used to decide who gets a last
delegate within a particular precinct
and that's true that's part of the
process check out this video of a coin
toss happening yesterday
[Applause]
in the end these single delegates
decided by a coin toss make very little
difference but it looks really silly
when people are voting and then you flip
a coin it's crazy
Trump then tweeting quote the Democrat
caucus is an unmitigated disaster
nothing works just like they ran the
country remember the five billion dollar
Obamacare website that should have cost
two percent of that the only person that
can claim a very big victory in Iowa
last night is Trump and you know what
guys he's right unfortunately this gives
a ton of visibility for their keep
government out of stuff ideology now in
reality the issue here is the DNC not
the government but it doesn't matter and
case in point Trump retweeting a guy I
know guy Benson who posted no but
seriously let us run your health care
they said now it's a complete wrong
reaction to last night's fiasco the DNC
wouldn't be running health care but
still this stuff works the fiasco plays
directly into everything that they are
arguing and have been doing for years at
this point in time and the way in which
this might again mess up the credibility
of the entire primary process is raining
once again and I'll explain what I mean
by that imagine that Joe Biden is
expecting to come in first or second
based on the polling and he ends up
fourth or fifth as he might end up based
on the early results we have after this
fiasco with a delay for quality control
followed by we just don't have any
results we'll get them to you hopefully
sometime tomorrow here Joe Biden you
were polling first second and you want
and you end up coming in fourth fifth
you immediately say I don't believe
these results I don't believe these
results can be trusted and you either
say foul play or just errors or whatever
the case may be and then you immediately
have a
disastrous situation where the
presumptive frontrunner at least for a
long time right is publicly saying I
don't trust our own results in this
primary caucus it's a disaster
it's an unmet to quote Trump it is an
unmitigated disaster for Democrats it
will further divide Democrats it will
help Donald Trump even more it's truly
sickening and it allows Trump and the
right it allows anyone who wants to make
the case that Democrats are incapable of
governing to make it on the basis that
they can't even get a caucus right now I
know that in the end there will probably
be explanations that go back to you know
it was whoever the technology was
outsourced to that dropped the ball and
they're offering a refund for what they
charge to make this app it doesn't
matter what matters is story and
narrative and that is the story right
now I'm curious whether tonight Donald
Trump will take advantage of this fiasco
in the State of the Union speech which
we will carry live on YouTube twitch and
Facebook starting at 8:30 the speeches
at 9:00 p.m.
join me early at 8:30 p.m. Eastern Time
I hope you'll join I have published
tonight's State of the Union bingo card
to my Twitter page at D Pakman you can
download it and play along we'll see who
who ends up with bingo tonight so I
mentioned this yesterday briefly but now
I want to dig into it more that we're
starting to get actual results from the
Iowa caucus Democratic candidate mayor
Pete Budaj edge is getting absolutely
crushed for having declared victory in
Iowa Monday night before any votes were
really counted you might remember that
when there was about 1 or 2 percent of
the vote in on Monday before all vote
reporting stopped because of the fiasco
involving the app being used to
communicate results in Iowa Budaj edge
was ahead for about 30 minutes by a
couple points than it went to Bernie but
it was meaningless because we had no
results at the time and Mayor Pete came
out and gave a victory speech and said
check out this video
but we know by the time it's all said
and done Iowa you have shocks the nation
and then take a look at you know that
this is a victory speech and there were
not yet any actual vote counts because
tonight an improbable hope became an
undeniable reality
[Applause]
[Music]
it's actually making me cringe there we
just didn't have a count and he's
basically giving a victory speech now
Amy Klobuchar did a speech as well but
she was just kind of positive she wasn't
really implying or saying she won or
even doing anything close to claiming
victory and then Buddha judge went on to
say on Twitter quote Iowa you have
shocked the nation by all indications we
are going on to New Hampshire victorious
hashtag Iowa caucuses
now based on the data we have as of this
filming Pete Buddha judge does have a
slight lead over Bernie Sanders but
there are essentially two possibilities
for what took place here and we're going
to discuss both of them he's getting
crushed the hashtag mayor cheat was
trending on Twitter he went on CBS
yesterday morning trying to explain
himself here's what he said
the Sanders campaign also saying they're
essentially victorious there are people
online saying that your claim of using
the V word is uh I think the hashtag is
mayor cheat in retrospect do you think
it was a little premature to take the
stage and use the V word no I mean
looking at what happened last night
looking at all of the data that we've
got it was an extraordinary night and we
are absolutely victorious coming into
New Hampshire I mean this is a campaign
that when we launched a year ago people
said you're not a senator you're not a
national name now he still didn't have
any results at the time that interview
was filmed and he's insisting that he's
victorious coming into New Hampshire so
he was kind of doubling down and also
backtracking kind of saying well listen
what I didn't mean I literally won what
I meant was that given the odds against
a mayor from a small town in Indiana as
a general thing regardless of the vote
totals I'm victorious merely because I
got some delegates and so I see myself
as victorious moving on to New Hampshire
so there's two possibilities here one is
that this is like a super grifter II
consultant idea some consultant came up
with hey let's just go out and claim
victory and then there will be headlines
and you'll do a speech and later we can
reinterpret it as I just meant that for
a small-town mayor to get delegates
that's a win we don't even need to know
the vote totals and in fact mayor
Pete was sort of a drifter consultant
himself so maybe it was actually his own
idea to do it
the real problem here is that this
doesn't stop with Mayor Pete in Iowa
once candidates get into this idea of
just claiming victory even before there
are votes no matter what you are opening
the door to candidates claiming they won
the Democratic nomination multiple
candidates claiming that they won even
if it hasn't actually been decided you
can get to November 3rd and Donald Trump
claiming he won even before we have the
actual numbers and then that becomes
what Trump supporters believe even if
later it turns out actually you didn't
win someone else went well but Trump
came out and said he claimed victory
it's a disastrous path to be going down
and this is 2020 American America that's
the unfortunate reality and we have to
be prepared for a version of this in
November and even for the lead-up to the
eventual nominee nominee on the
Democratic side to have this type of
victory claim absent actual evidence now
there's another side to this and we're
gonna dig into this more in a little bit
there is the idea because a connection
has been found between a consultancy
group working on the Iowa caucus and
mayor Pete there's the idea that the
reason mayor Pete went out and claimed
victory was because he already knew that
the vote counts would be manipulated in
his favor
and he would ultimately reign victorious
now I think it's important that you know
we find connections on Republican sides
and sometimes they're meaningful and
sometimes they're not and what you
really have to understand is that in the
incestuous world of politics and power
in the United States it's not surprising
to keep running into the same people
frequently and we have to be more
discerning than that right when Trump
says he doesn't know left Parnas and
Parnas keeps showing up in videos
talking to Trump about Murray Ivanovic
and whatever else at a certain point it
starts to be like radula T when it comes
to the mayor Pete thing I don't think
that we should attribute to malice
what can be explained by incompetence
but I am NOT saying there is
definitively nothing to see here when it
comes to these consultant groups and
mayor Pete let's talk about that more in
the next segment because it is it's
important that we get this sort of under
control before people go too far with it
let's talk about John Bolton briefly
there are multiple new reports out that
Donald Trump is keeping a list of people
who crossed him during his presidency
who he would like to get locked up
eventually and his own former national
security adviser John Bolton is
reportedly on that list we heard this
from Rick Wilson we've had Rick on the
show longtime Republican strategist he's
an anti-trump Republican he says that
Donald Trump is likely to start putting
pressure on the Justice Department to
try to get revenge on people like Bolton
Bolton of course recently saying that in
his upcoming book in the manuscript
portion that was released says that
Donald Trump personally told him
withhold the Ukraine aid until Ukraine
smears Joe Biden publicly of course the
Senate is expected to vote to acquit
Donald Trump tomorrow Wednesday in the
Senate Rick Wilson says that John Bolton
has one choice right now and that John
Bolton must leak the full manuscript of
the book today
the reason Wilson says this is that if
Bolton doesn't leak the full transcript
with additional context and assertions
related to what Trump told him about
Ukraine Trump gets acquitted tomorrow
and then ruins Bolton's life Wilson says
Bolton's only shot is to try to get the
full story out today of what he saw
Trump do get it into the public before
the Senate votes to make the vote look
like a sham kangaroo court vote which of
course is exactly what that vote will be
investigative reporter Gabriel Sherman
says it's not just Bolton on Trump's
enemies list it's Republicans and
Democrats Adam Schiff is on Trump's list
Jerry Nadler is on Trump's list even
Republican Senator Mitt Romney from Utah
is reportedly on that list I can imagine
this list of enemies written in crayon
on a napkin from Kentucky Fried Chicken
that Trump was eating on Air Force One
but it doesn't matter because this is a
disco
be in reality Sherman reports that he
was told Trump wants John Bolton
criminally investigated one possibility
would be for the mishandling of
classified information that Trump seems
to think John Bolton was engaged in
which is truly even a crew call the pot
pot calling the kettle black when he
were Donald Trump talking about miss
handling sensitive information there's
another report that Trump wants to leak
emails showing that Bolton was doing
pay-to-play while on the National
Security Council that's been denied by
people close to Bolton if this happens
the transition to full-blown
authoritarian dictatorship will be
complete the attempted jailing of former
elected officials and of administration
officials on trumped up charges as
directed by the president now this is a
good opportunity to clarify something we
need elected officials held more
accountable than they are held I have no
problem with elected officials current
and former being investigated as part of
a fair judicial process we lack that we
have this de facto immunity that so many
of our elected officials and our elites
have merely because they are in a
position of power but you don't do it by
having the president make a list of
enemies that wants that he wants revenge
on and then forcing the Justice
Department to investigate them this is
exactly why though I'm saying
there have been no consequences for
Donald Trump's actions so why wouldn't
he do this
Russia probe possible cognitive decline
hush money payments campaign finance
violations hiding his taxes emoluments
violations and he's fine he's continuing
to be President he's making the u.s. a
laughingstock why wouldn't he be
emboldened by that and say hey let me
make a list of enemies and I'll try to
get them jailed sometime soon because
he's gotten away with everything so far
and unless we vote him out on November
third he will likely succeed at
triggering at least some investigation
of his political enemies he will get
away with all of it as far as John
Bolton I hope it's clear to him he has
one choice it's not even really a choice
when there's only one he has to spill
the beans period as far as love Parnas I
he publishes everything he has including
every video he has access to but in the
meantime this authoritarian nightmare
has to be stopped one way or the other
and there's really no the other right
now the one way is vote him out
overwhelmingly on November 3rd because
nothing else is having any effect let me
know what you think I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman make sure you're following me
there we now have as of this recording
71% of precincts reporting in Monday
night's Iowa caucus I will talk later
about how Iowa should not be the first
in the nation primary more on that later
or tomorrow the results didn't come into
US on Monday night because of the total
crash of the technology used to report
results in Iowa and we had a very
embarrassing 24 hours for the Iowa
Democratic Party and for the Democratic
National Committee and 62% of results
were released yesterday Tuesday
afternoon as of this recording we've
gotten another 9 percentage points of
the results 71 percent have been
released most analysts believe that Pete
Budaj
who is now leading will be the eventual
winner of the Iowa caucus now remember
these are proportional delegate
allocations so it will be a
mathematically meaningless victory for
Budaj edge relative to Bernie Sanders in
the grand scheme of things but we'll
come back to that looking at the results
as if a few minutes ago Pete Budaj edge
with just under 27 percent of the
delegates Bernie Sanders with just over
25 percent of the delegates
despite as you might notice Bernie
having more votes in the popular vote as
of discounting you'll notice Elizabeth
Warren in third place with about 18% Joe
Biden in fourth place with 15 percent
and Biden followed very closely by
senator Amy Klobuchar with about 12 and
a half percent of the vote the only
other people getting any delegates are
Andrew yang with 1% and Tom Steyer with
0.3% everybody else including Michael
Bloomberg and Tulsi Gabbard with literal
goose eggs just zeros now without going
into the detail the reason that Pete can
have
more delegates while Bernie has more raw
votes it's similar to how you can win
the electoral college but lose the
popular vote the way Donald Trump did in
2016 the delegates are apportioned at a
local level and you can win some
precincts with a big popular vote margin
but then lose a lot of little priests
are a lot of lose a lot of other
precincts by small margins and end up
with a popular vote win and without the
most delegates we don't yet have the
final numbers in the end more than
likely this will mean 10 pledged
delegates for Pete and 10 pledged
delegates for Bernie they might end up
differing by one or two that's as of
right now we are still waiting on that
last twenty nine percent of the vote
this does not put anybody in any kind of
a decisive position we will very quickly
get another democratic debate this
Friday we will then go right to the New
Hampshire primary on Tuesday which will
be 24 more delegates in total Bernie
right now very much in the lead in New
Hampshire so remember this is one of
four primaries before March 3rd Super
Tuesday the delegates are apportioned
proportionately and the DNC is
increasingly panicking about Joe Biden's
poor performance and Bernie's good
performance we'll talk a little bit
later about the idea that's being
floated about giving super-delegates the
power they had in 2016 which had been
taken away from them in New Hampshire
Bernie Sanders remember Bernie won
handily in the 2016 New Hampshire
primary he had about 60% of the vote to
Hillary Clinton's 38% massive victory in
New Hampshire in 2016 but again it's 24
delegates Iowa was 41 New Hampshire is
only 24 the big repercussion here is not
for Budaj edge or for Bernie the big
repercussions here are for Joe Biden Joe
Biden's terrible performance has shaken
the establishment to its core and later
in the show we're going to dig into that
in more detail Elizabeth Warren's poor
performance also leading to some deep
thinking about her future she got just
four pledged delegates and is currently
polling
in fourth place in New Hampshire very
unlikely New Hampshire will give Warren
any momentum there was a report
yesterday I don't know if it's been
confirmed that she has been canceling
and rescheduling a lot of planned travel
to both Nevada and South Carolina the
third and fourth primary states it does
not seem like things are going well for
Warren and really they haven't been for
about I think about six or seven weeks
at this point that we've been covering
so those are the numbers as of right now
in the Iowa caucus results by the time
you watch this clip by the time we
published today's show we may have 100%
of the results or closer to it but
generally speaking these are the results
a over performance by Pete Budaj
significant under performance by Joe
Biden and Bernie Sanders roughly
percentage-wise with the level of
support that the polls indicated going
in make sure you're following the David
Pakman show on Instagram for more on
this and other stories at David Pakman
show
in today's disgusting but totally
unsurprising news Donald Trump allegedly
referred to MSNBC reporter Katie Tours
transgender mom as a [ __ ]
with a [ __ ] dad those are the
president's alleged words so I'm allowed
to save him this is from a new book
called sinking in the swamp by Lachlan
Marquis and a so win sub sang Katie tor
is the daughter of Zoe tor you might
remember Zoe tour from the OJ Simpson
low-speed helicopter car chase in that
white Bronco in 1994 if you were around
then Zoe tour doesn't like Trump and Zoe
tour is a trans woman and the book
alleges that Donald Trump makes horrible
comments about women all the time he
called Megan McCain the daughter of the
late Senator John McCain dumber than her
father pointed out that she's been
getting fatter after she said things on
the view that Trump didn't like this
actually started with Trump getting into
it with Katy tour herself when he was
running for president writing off her
questions sometimes during interviews
when he didn't want to answer one of her
questions he would say oh give me a
break next question Katie very very
condescending he started calling her
little
Katie started calling her a third-rate
journalist all of that stuff and once
when she tried to follow up a question
with Trump he simply said be quiet
then of course we get to these latest
allegations that Trump referred to Katie
tore privately as again a [ __ ] with a
[ __ ] dad referring to Katie Tours
transgender mom this is the president
now he will have defenders no matter
what he says and lots of people probably
agree with him there's a lot of people
in this country I don't know if it's you
know 15% 17% that are extremely
anti-trans and while they probably would
never be willing to say what Donald
Trump is accused of saying they aren't
gonna get too upset about hearing that
Donald Trump said it that's one group
there's also people who don't
necessarily even agree with Trump
attacking trans people but they do
generally want things to sort of go back
to the way they imagined things were in
the 1950s and they see treating trans
people respectfully as something that's
not quite in line with their 1950s ideal
so they're not really gonna get bent out
of shape about attacking trans people
but they're not gonna go and do it
themselves and then of course remember
first lady milania's Trump's big
initiative was going to be ending
bullying fighting bullying and her
husband is one of the biggest bullies of
all sorts of different groups of people
based on their identity that we know of
I wish it weren't the case but too many
people either like comments like these
or they're just indifferent as long as
Trump won't let Mexicans in the country
right or whatever their priority is it's
one of those areas where we just need to
change the dialogue completely a
different president could do that we
talked about lots of the things that
would take a long time to change and
Trump didn't create racism Trump didn't
create xenophobia or anti trans bias or
anti-semitism but when he says things
like this when he doesn't do anything
about the coalescing and growing
extremist movements he makes the people
who are into those ideologies emboldened
and more comfortable publicly displaying
their beliefs
if Trump leaves the White House in a
year
that's not going to change the views of
these extremists but it might put them
back at least in a little bit of a more
hidden position in society where they
might think twice about going public
with these views and then over time
hopefully those views will continue to
dissipate or age out as we like to say
we can hope
imagine being Katie tor and finding out
that the president referred to a parent
of yours in this way it's almost
inconceivable or at least it would have
been in 2015 but this is 2020 United
States and this story barely makes
headlines in the midst of everything
else that's going on really really
shocking stuff